the green agenda if pressed
incompetently in political terms with
the wrong compelling messages imposed on
people in the wrong ways will actually
delay the Green Revolution V and we just
had a perfect example here but people
are saying always be very careful about
gas expansion and we've done to share
gas America's fine but we don't want to
see too much encouragement here what is
the net effect of that the net effect is
that American coal is pouring into
Europe we're burning more coal here in
this country Europe's cold as a whole is
increasing the actual on Germans are
planning new caliphates stations with
and co2 while informing falling to
America to the twenty twenty year level
lowest level and forum fourteen percent
in the last two years and the per capita
emissions has fallen dramatically so
it's not just a recession issue well I
challenging yeah because you have chosen
a quite a two year horizon in a time of
yoga low us growth i can i call you on
that well you can call me but the 57
million extra people in america in the
last 20 years and yet the carbon co2
emissions up now twenty percent aren't
they are very left